everybody welcome to street cocoa oh
yeah you clap in the pack what we're
very very excited enough clapping we're
very excited today because as you see
our couch is full of professional
eSports players we've got a special
stream coming at you from our friends at
Google Play we're going to be going
through the nitty-gritty of clash Royale
a little ditty called clash Royale maybe
you've heard of it available on Google
Play and we've got some amazing players
here the number one ranked team in the
country complexity Colton wall give it
up so if you're doing a lot of applause
breaks here a lot of a fuzzy Michael
razza Roper Roper is also cool yeah I
mean Rovers are pretty cool nickname
also but you went rahzar Adrian Piedra
practicing that name all night alright
so guys say hi to the chat we are live
on YouTube Twitter Facebook of course
hello everybody hey tree wolf hastin
reggie lumber zach dancing spatula how's
it all going so I know very little about
clash Royale so what have you guys are
here so here's the deal so supercell
hooked us up and unlocked all these
amazing cards so Colton firt the people
at home who might have never heard of
clash Royale how would you describe it
other than an amazingly super fun game
it's a live either 1v1 or to be to tower
taking game okay where you have a finit
amount of resource which is called a
lick sir that builds up to 10 and every
card has a different cost yes so
typically the more expensive ones are
the bigger units that do more things
have more HP more health got it
and so you dropped these on your side of
the arena and then they perform their
ability or their task and then they
execute that and then
you have troops and spells in both you
and your teammate both you and your
opponent will use those back and forth
to see who can eventually take the tower
of your opponent typical Saturday night
in my apartment me versus the roaches so
yeah so and this is really cool we have
all these amazing cards and I love like
what what are some of your favorite card
do you have a favorite card let's go
down the line Colton uh probably
graveyard which is a spell but also kind
of like it wears graveyard on here what
just take just take this for me all
right so all right so why is graveyard
your favorite it spawns skeletons around
the tower and those skeletons will
attack the tower whoo all right very
nice alright as ur yep um I smell why is
it razor why is it like Jay Z where when
you were a child like that Roper kind of
morphed into a rather well no it's it's
because growing up our our child our
family dog was named razor I don't know
how they got the name but I like after
your family dog adage it that is great I
love it rather I mean razza has gone to
the great dog yard guy okay great dog
yards not a thing all right sorry Oh
favorite card rather my favorite card is
the ice wizard probably Oh fantastic
because it's cheap I was like my father
emotionally cold sorry pops
go on it's it's cheap it slows things
and yeah it's about to get buff so even
better so and for people I don't know
buffing means it's gonna they're gonna
make it better
yes and what's the opposite of buffing
nerfect nerfing exactly all right now
Adrian what about you yeah well my bark
knee
so all right well limb trash can on
wheels but she's really cool there we go
I need some math work oh I love it all
right well cool all right so let's get
into it I think the first thing we want
to do is make a sweet deck right so
I'm gonna play one of you now who wants
to go up against me first
I can they drew straws and you got the
shortest straw all right so I'm gonna
make a deck and by the way in the chat
you guys let us know what kind of decks
you want us to make burn thing says blue
moon wolf all right I shall burn things
unless you're saying burn our studio and
it is very hot in here so we're burning
up that's right yeah so BIM BAM boom
yeah so now when you're when you're
creating a deck what are some of the the
tenets of a good deck what do I want in
a deck you want a win condition which is
a unit that does damage to the right so
help me out here you guys vs team we
won't look at the screen and you don't
look at this all right let's help me out
here so this can't be embarrassed the
very first battle oh god oh no the giant
isn't one condition because it's
something that only targets buildings
it's like a big large unit that will go
up and punch the build the tower okay
good I like a giant so your unit your
purpose is to like get that to the tower
and you do that by having like support
troops like a good troopers hey a mouth
full of my town Luigi yeah yeah sorry so
we got the giant here yeah there we go
so he's good boom he's pretty basic I
like kissing you know what I'm into I'm
just gonna say right now I like the
facial hair I might kind of I'm just
gonna warn you cold and I might be
gravitating a little more towards better
facial hair the cards I know that's not
the way you play this game but I do like
that the bar oh yes this is what I'm
look at this guy yeah that's great
that's very Hulk Hogan esque you can use
him as like a way to kill enemy tanks
like Giants I love it alright oh look at
this guy
oh and this is great that's great facial
hair too let's get rid of skeletons they
don't have any fish eye it took me a
long time as a child to grow a beard so
I you know it's I'm really into this I
love you like the cat you're like one of
the best players like in the world
you're like this flying thing yes the
log is
the lodge so what happens is a small
spell it cost to look to you okay and it
rolls and it knocks things backs and
damages it oh my god that's great
typically you have like fireball or
zapper log but log is cooler so alright
cool another another support it's like
popular I'm just building a deck but
Gingrich says blegh revered as a child
no I didn't I had to wear a fake beard
until I was like 30 give him a barbs he
burps whoops
ivar he's one of the most powerful oh
yeah where's the bar he's like by this
bar there we go the bar some elite
Barb's bro you know my elite Barb's
there's one thing about me they have a
helmet so that makes them special yeah
it does and also kind of yeah kind of
again it's kinda helmets kind of coming
up the mustaches I'm not into using the
lumberjack castle oh okay well do
lumberjack and sit yeah that's a nice
beard yeah beard oh there we go look at
that that's an amazing beer alright now
you guys got your deck art I don't want
to take us through your deck oh let's
see their day I want to see what I'm
going up that's not good for me at all
also can we talk about very quickly
these guys got me at Jersey look at this
great Jersey I'm wearing yeah that's
like and can I just turn around here
that's right I'm a member of your team
your team is no longer gonna have be
ranked number one or be six and one
they're gonna take away wins alright so
take us through your deck here let's see
we got well as you may see here I have
lots of flying thing Oh No oh god he's
just preying on my my my roach
infestation in my apartment that i just
opened up to you guys about that's
basically that's why you guys are pros
you're getting in my mind it's a mental
game really clash royale is not just
it's not about a strategy it's also
about getting in the mind of your
opponent I like it basically we have
mosquitos
I don't take the wheel Colton please w8
III take the wheel you guys are just
joining us we are playing clash royale
today with our accessible partner google
play available now of course like I even
need to say that it's like the most
popular game in the world that's right
Conan by the way will be joining us a
little bit later so everybody's saying
Conan or riot don't riot quite yet like
to riot so Conan comes in and then he'll
write it with us it's pretty great
that's right leave it that's right yeah
leave it leave it now you guys have a
match tonight at 6:00 that's great very
exciting check these guys out
youtube.com slash eSports royale and you
guys are playing hold on wait I wrote it
down a lot of things in my brain counter
logic gaming yes this keeps you humble
yes keep you home all right fantastic
okay cool so let's do it I think I have
to send a yeah good luck good except if
you dare Rosser I'm pretty nervous
except there all right all right we're
in it all right you know I'm actually
I'm actually a bit nervous all right oh
you're emoting wait how do I need move
back at these guys yeah to show you my
muscles well you know what I should do
is just start I should start attacking
her okay all right so what's kind of
what's a good strategy or walk me
through this start thing to the back so
that you can be like slow okay don't you
have a limited amount of elixir you'll
run out soon okay wait like play the
wizard like behind your tower wizard
this guy also kind of I'm gonna be
honest he looks a little like a douche
he's kind of like got like the goatee
which I have a goatee and he's like a
hood it's like me like trying to get
into a club let me in do you attack both
sides would you just go up oh my god
that's so many skeletons there we go my
man yes
no lecture that's okay
there's a lot of stuff coming up the
Wrights oh my god oh the right side man
this is gnarly
Oh God oh I think they killed one other
no what was the thing that we just my
one of my towers destroyed and then it
turned into 19 other guys get a lava
hound so it's like a big lava hound dog
my god that'll die instantly are you
guys just loving the boy around this is
great okay there we go so basically like
terrible like this guy is a real problem
we just can we just talk out our
problems is there a way you know I'm
gonna food is that food poisoning or is
that just regular poison watch a like a
bad okay well I got okay Oh for one you
know what warm-up rounds that one does
warm-ups the warm-up round you know I
feel like I learned a little bit there
so you go do go what is the deal are you
mostly defensive or mostly offensive or
because you don't know what the other
team is gonna play and then they're deck
yeah so so typically the way you should
start a game is by either letting them
play first and then reacting with
something in the back on your own side
okay we're just starting something slow
on your side that takes a long time
across the bridge okay like I said you
haven't got yeah you have a finit amount
of elixir so once you get the tin you
should play something but should be in
the back so you can wait and feel them
out cuz like how you started the game
was just putting something out of the
bridge go when you instantly have no
elixir right and he defends it and then
everything that he used to kill your
troops then counter pushes and he got it
because he got ahead with the elixir
right away because I was an idiot
all right well you guys are correctly
wrong you guys are the number one 2v2
team right yeah so I want to see you
guys battle each other let's tear this
team apart right I'm getting in their
mind already see what I'm doing here for
my next match they're gonna like really
hate each other and like
this I can't wait to see this it's gonna
be perfect
yeah exactly my man fantastic again we
are we're playing clash royale double
now from our exclusive mobile partners
Google Play that's right
did I say something about hot pockets I
did because I'm starving I'm so hungry
all the time and no no mod of elixir is
going to help although I was joking
earlier elixir my life is coffee so just
I can't do anything if I run out of
coffee I literally just curl up on the
ground until an intern comes and just
pours it on me and just my body sucks it
up like osmosis exactly a Trudeau had
any kind of pregame rituals or
superstitions that kind of you do where
you before every game before last I love
to hear music like oh like what are we
talking like show tunes like Hamilton or
you go like Slayer like what are we
talking you uh most likely music in
Spanish yeah
cumbia and things like that like yeah
there's always dancing in the locker
room you yeah so embarrassing yeah I try
but what they're not saying is it's slow
dancing it's like middle school they're
both just he gets jealous when I dance
with your essence oh wow
learning a lot about complexities right
you guys can cook all the way Thank You
Romar and we are here with complexity
these guys amazing tree Joneses team
that's so cool very exciting yeah
headquarters the star in Texas very fun
yeah that's fantastic and how is it and
and how is it working under those guys
the training all that stuff is it is it
pretty into it yeah currently we're in
LA but typically we have apartments and
and they're building our headquarters in
the star as well yeah I heard about that
I think it should be known next year
which is very cool yeah so but you know
of course the danger in Texas is the
queso is amazing so
stay away from a case event such before
matches fines yep and that an issue I
can't leak that's very yellow eat cheese
exactly man you guys get cheese all over
your tablet your Android tablet it's
crazy ready to go
hey Brock how's it going all right you
guys ready yeah oh man this is actually
gonna be very exciting this is nobody
wants to see me play they want to see
these guys play exactly here we go way
to start the match huh yeah and yeah you
can select what if we we should say we
should get our emo deck
we should tweak our you mode right now
we have like 48 emo Barb's that's me on
the 405 I know for a meeting of I think
for me to get pumped up for a match it
would just be being in traffic for 10
minutes or just getting no amount of
music or dancing can get you more pumped
out oh my god here we go
see messing around the Evo's that go
blink if somebody's got their eyes on
the prize here yeah battle right oh my
god
we need that goofy mode for you 9 it's
true oh oh
depends he'll flash around around that's
right clash royale better than the
fortnight I agree baby like damn do you
have a favorite you got a favorite Rina
you like playing a favorite board like
to play like and I know they're kind of
all the same but in terms of like
visually do you late like oh okay yeah
what are you into if you could design
your own board what would it be love
right back atcha Tobias take a playhouse
what's that Barb's take a place there so
oh there we go our man yes this is my
favorite game I know it's amazing
don't elixir now we're in a bad son
death and that's the new card the golden
giant so up aggressive green
oh I don't know if that battering-ram
talking too much
usually they the valorem is good
indifference because it responds to
Barb's directly in the tamoxifen there
we go perfect so usually is like super
good wing conditions because you need to
log it a building to stop it if no he
goes like it's crap I will say what's so
insane I was watching a lot of videos
about this game the strategy is insane
how do you guys keep up with the amount
of different cards and all of the in
like crazy because it just seems like
shifting everything is always shifting
all the time these you need to put only
eight cards yeah I love exactly I used
to be really smart when you write it
just like what you're gonna play versus
what you're gonna play and well
basically there you build the deck also
what you feel more comfortable sharing
of course with what you have fun right
if you don't have fun with the game well
great what's the point yeah how did you
first how did you first get into class
RAL well he's he's like out when he's
thirty because I'm doing my back uh-huh
I was playing bass yeah it's a hilarious
story I got horribly and I get terrible
and I need to stay like in bed for a
while yeah and I just started playing oh
my god I got something to do and well
you just changed my life that's crazy
now you're amazing wow that's good it's
like football or soccer for you
Americans very low scoring game is the
most exciting exactly during the death
list what's up with you uh alright so
how do you feel you guys did let's get a
little bit early it was a close game
let's create let's critique each other's
performance golf and John's not very
strong but three Moscow nur is graveyard
in general yeah so I have no idea what
you just said explain what that means to
me and the people at home what is that
so like the cards he has have a slight
advantage over the ones I'm using okay I
also miss played cuz I was emoting and I
miss
three three three muscular cards usually
split so there's three musketeers and
you split them in the back okay if
you're really fast with tornado you can
pull them all in the same Lane it makes
it easier to kill them
wait so tornado post all these cards
together and which means they can be
killed in the air more easily instead of
them splitting you got it online so
that's what I was trying to do but I was
emoting priorities and the emo decks
aren't fixed so so you have eight emotes
in your deck uh-huh and then you in game
you can scroll over so I was busy
scrolling through the emos trying to get
the one perfect well maybe we should
tweak our emote is what I'm hearing from
the caption of complexity he was unhappy
with the emotes that I chose fair enough
I don't like the basic ones okay you
know I didn't realize emotes were such
an important part of class right now it
it's mine game it's great that's so
great I love it
do you most really a residue emotes
really get you upset if somebody's
emoting hard at you oh not really I kind
of ignore it but I don't really care
yeah this bum the bar later alright let
us know in the chat by the way we're
streaming on of course YouTube Facebook
at which let us know if you guys want to
see a particular deck let us know I want
to go like the next game I want to go
like goblins V skeletons or something
you know the full skeleton they yeah
they're a false Kelly deck as I call it
that's what the cool kids say I ate her
in full Skelly done he likes eating
better than play well any I know you
should play me because I need a win
under my belt I'm 0 and 1 so maybe I
complain you can't emo yeah yeah what
kind of training now what kind of
training do you guys do what kind of
training is involved in clash Royale
training either like playing against
each other 1 B 1 or 2 V 2 since we have
a team of 5 where
to do that with TV - right and then uh
what sometimes we scratch and the odd
man out just dances or something yeah
yeah by the way you got the other two
members your team right here that's
right they dance they are dancers back
that's what they're yeah I wish there
was a dance deck in clash Royale super
so get on that let's get it all right we
got some super Kingdom right yeah
whatever the King does this by the way
this is there we go yeah I got it I kind
of need the dough we need that emote
dancing yeah exactly
we can't pay for any music here but just
put some music out of your house so emo
yeah Katy Perry I would enjoy or some
t-swift of course I like that do you
guys have no Roger do you have pregame
rituals or anything besides dancing with
a dream which I I do a couple of
different things I I do listen to music
I love just listening to music focusing
up and I also text my dad before we go
there we go
so I just text him wish me luck and he
says good luck I thought you're gonna
say like you troll your dad that's cool
that's great are you superstitious or no
like if your dad doesn't text you back
will you still go and play uh no dad we
need to fight I'm not a dad
superstitious but yeah I do like it text
back oh there yeah I've never not gotten
a text back so if I don't then I've my
panic yeah mr. Alford please stay by
your phone for any man very important
very important Cole what about you I get
up you also text rousers dad no again I
jump up and like dance around and listen
to music and stuff like a party man I
want to I'm sure it looks a little bit
weirder if you're like watching us
because we have headphones on it's a
silent
[Laughter]
all right here we go
goblins vs. skeletons whose goblets and
whose skeletons go alright here we go
let's see I'm predicting goblins what do
you think what are you gonna predict
these are cops cops are skills let's go
throw some more on knowing you like more
to store army tell me about it buildings
are more forward it constantly talking
about how thin they are it's the worst
we get it skeletons give a low body fat
percentage also I love the a skillet
don't seem oh yeah yeah oh you love the
skillet dad we have we'd love a heart
like that now see I can see constantly
doing that a moat would get in my head
for sure definitely how often do they
how often do they do game changes or add
cards to this game well yeah we have
monthly balance name isn't it monthly
balance changes Wow so you guys are
really kept on your toes yeah that's
crazy
and how are they and the last balance
changes were they did they change again
significantly or is it only really
tweaks like they get buff but then now
they get last a slightly in there yeah
so that's like better for the health hey
chat let's hear it scales are gobs you
team scaler team god I suck team goalie
yeah exactly
I said yeah Steve spell II to gobby
gobby
[Music]
that's great I love that emote that's
emo
they have an email base of my sister
which is amazing well done supercell my
sister died all sorts of sure it works
for the show as well we used to share an
office and we used to sit like this
close to each other like where that
chair is and you guys have siblings I
okay yeah and so we were getting to find
two people sit between us we get into
fights we both call each other and turn
towards the wall how does my beard work
I don't know it's I'm not sure how a
beard works exactly oh here we go we got
the skellies we got gah beause I think I
think we got it's about even but I think
team Gobbo I think people are more on
the gobs that's nasty no skeletons man
um I will never not be afraid of
skeletons I think in a fight I can
probably take a goblin you know for the
skeleton like how do you fight against
the skeleton okay alive
discuss yelling foreground are you tied
up
I think it's like I do lovely this game
it's like it's beautiful and very cute
but in real life these he's got to be
horrified like a dark goblin in real
life it's been horrifying if you see
also thing that going do I know like
what are we doing that's right hope
somebody's same coating Royale I love it
yes vex Ian this stream is we are
playing clash royale some of the
greatest players to play the game
Colton Michael and Adrian and their team
complexity and we are doing this in
partnership with our friends at Google
Play our exclusive mobile gaming partner
playing stuff with Google Play all year
we did a 24 hour stream yes we're so
amazing a lot of people in this room
24 hours to be a lot of laughter to the
back ah a lot of pizza all the snacks
we're amazing in any way oh well we
couldn't quite go hard cases we're all
in one room if you feel me you know so I
don't want to go caso in the small room
in the 24 hour stream but but yes that
was also with our friends at Google Play
so we're really excited all right I want
to go again man I want to go again can
you construct me a great deck but also
like a great you know because between us
Colton I'm going hard in the emotes yeah
for you got a match number too hard on
me and it makes these things so what was
the screaming is a screen you guys ever
petitioned supercell like for like
please make an emote that does this we
had one like make a lumberjack Laurie
something that was pretty cool
oh that's awesome yeah he has like a
rage potion and he was like drinking it
I know how are you guys are you guys
friendly with the other teams or not so
much is it pretty competitive or you
guys kind of all know each other I mean
it's competitive but we all know each
other yeah we're all friends that's
correct the end of the day I know
antique complexity it's not just class
right now you guys I think you guys have
won 140 championships over 30 titles
that's amazing
unbelievable complexity is the
longest-standing esports order yeah yeah
founded I think in my scrawled notes
with 2003 yes crazy yes in about 15
years which is crazy so when I was one
because I'm 16 years old when I was one
laughing I just went great early you
know yeah
Matalin Sid says the 24 hours he was
yeah that was very intense it was a very
intense 24 hours dream a lot of fun
that was team no sleep for sure that was
great
yeah let's make it make something I'm
gonna strike fear into the hearts of
these fools I'm sorry I got you know the
time I want them to remember my name
what's written on the back of my shirt
I'm gonna leave them in the dust all
they're gonna see his blade say no more
cut to me losing three crowns to zero
and yeah you guys this is obviously this
is on Google Play now so download it now
and play and this is great and we've
super so it was nice enough to unlock a
bunch of great cards for us so these
cards are this is a massive amount of
cards we get to play with today
what's the hog what somebody's saying
something about a hog that's a hog okay
Oh perfect perfect
well he's that's the hog rider ya know
the hog rider right and I'm guessing
it's a real hog not a motorcycle right
yeah yeah he's so spicy so spicy
it's a piggy are there any throwing logs
in a trampoline but gay are there any
trampoline carts I don't think there are
any trampoline all right here we go wait
so what you're saying is if I lose it's
my own fault
yeah all right here we go all right
first of all okay I'm gonna start yeah
I'm going hard minutes head get in his
head get in his head all right step two
all right okay wait oh God okay wait
those don't do that much damage but all
right good so what so I'm gonna let him
attend plate all the way in the back
decide the game yeah all right all right
I mean I should always start in the back
do we like our skeletons in the back I
started in the back left maybe back
laughter am i man
I probably kill them put this through
the tombstone what is the two stones
it's a building that will pull the Giant
and yeah there we go no what about this
dude with a huge awesome beard can I get
him out of that thing he's attacking now
I do like fire and setting things on
fire can I throw a fireball somewhere
there's like fireballs in New Year's
bugs on they go on the goat way up right
here right here I'd that right there
there you go Oh get him boys get him ah
you know bar Keith I doesn't matter of
course I think those barbarians should
be wearing some kind of armor they're
going shirtless see look they weren't
wearing in the circus I got killed
immediately put some arm round Rocketeer
this thing is terrible this is doable
you need to surround that with skeletons
okay let's surround it I'm just gonna
drop a bunch of skellies go after coming
from the back from the other I don't
know this is the first time I'm hearing
the hog rider remote and that's not what
I expected yeah you and me both
all right here we go so played the can I
please play the beer guy in the back
first okay we're playing at the bridge
right at the bridge right at the bridge
yeah go giant go baby go get him
is that a bald spot all right sorry I'm
getting ad sorry
now you're a puppy no a sock that's our
hog rider he did damage
I got a do mr. t did I at least hurt him
yeah you did damage dude I got to do
something here come on
[Laughter]
glad you guys are amused to my death
scene I think that's what it is yeah all
right yessir anima Skelly's that the one
fighting boys I remember Cole I think
it's too late for you now yeah you know
I've never seen let's go over right
before it's very quick it's alright I
need to start in the back more right cuz
it takes muscle at the beginning yeah
all right yeah I think I'm still
recovering waves tiny flag yes exactly
that's me I should have just brought a
surrender flag that I could just be
confident there's a Nemo that's what I
need let's add that surrender Nemo
and it is a goblin way that's right uh
which one you only get rid of well not
not my boys over here you know this
guy's kind of lame what's happening here
you see this tongue yeah who cares about
all right let's uh Skelly's Skelly's
it's Kelly's are the way to go all right
um let me just make a deck quick I'm no
wine its policy cream did you see me do
this I was they're not gonna see it
being broadcast to everybody all right I
I got hurt with these bad so I'm gonna
put this in here it's Sparky right
Hadrian yes yes my boy Sparky and it
doesn't matter if I put him on time to
the bottom right no really trying to not
do the mustaches but I'm drawn towards
this mustache guy he's good that that's
the way to pick which somebody said at
one point or residen you asked if I had
a witch and I didn't I was Adrian didn't
send me out yeah so should I put what is
the witch - good - puss Kelly's yeah
what's that bond skeleton okay it's good
behind a tank all right perfect
she's got glowing eyes she's kind of you
know she's fierce looking maybe get
Barb's get rid of the porno we like this
dude kind of he's not doing also he
looks kind of scared you know he'd
switch my thing real quick with you
three clothes let's guy in the upper
left here giant yeah this is not like he
looks like he's you know he looks like
he's frightened you know all right boy
perfect uh so what's happening here this
guy looks like he's in a barrel and
farting yeah he's a barbarian the bar in
a barrel he's cute he's kid all right
fight it's like monkey in a barrel but
with a barb okay all right I mean I
guess this is okay right I feel like
you're kind of looking at this with
disdain if you say so
uh if you're feeling it just trust
yourself
Crosswhite that's the worst piece of
advice I've ever but I'm going to go
with my gut and my gut says do it all
right so here let's start it up
all right here we go then you need to
eat more more hope you're ready
I think that's bad advice but I'm gonna
take it exactly here we go
yeah just screaming at each other have
you guys ever seen clash royale cosplay
people dress up that's kind of some of
these things I went to Spain I saw a
couple of people you did yeah that's
cool with it just as like a witch
[Music]
parking in the back Sparky in the back
yeah you need to fire both the pump
fireball the fireball that was a pump oh
yeah that doesn't come activated until
you take a tower or you maybe they're
just trying to desalinate the water you
know to get better Wow you can start
your sparking The Bachelor key in the
back sparking the back left there we go
baby
hydration BOTS yes hydration bodies
really I'm trying to clash the meows oh
you're playing turqoise deck wait what
deck is it wet what Zach there's a
player on one ladder that's popular for
rain this day okay and he's like that
looks like a throw you guys are so
finely tuned you knew immediately what
deck you I think that's crazy I mean
it's part of what you have to do right
I'm sure yeah work at this level it's
crazy so Colton take me weird like
what's a normal day for you guys can I
put the real giant here or something
yeah okay I mean yeah means no well you
are leaking is why would you get the ten
you just need to play something oh I see
is a normal day is like we wake up we
eat and then I get to practicing the
forms are practice very
either teammates are like going over
like analytical type stuff because we
have analysts as well whoa that's crazy
they just offend yeah it's good to like
know your opponent well throw your throw
your bomb in a barrel my barber in a
barrel there you go they're coming back
barbar yeah no shirts I don't get but
just like put a shirt all right can we
try me just like playing with one of you
guys with your eyes closed
can we just like it let's just do a
rematch same thing like close your eye
and no peeking no peeking
I'm going up against the captain of
complexity mr. Colten wall and he's
gonna keep his eyes closed and I'm and
I'm gonna try to beat him which means
you know and I'm just saying not looking
at this but like you don't know where it
is on the tablet you don't even know I
don't know what card I'm exactly you
have no idea we can know which card we
yeah Lord you guys are like ninjas Oh do
they like blindfold you and they even
like ice wizard at the beginning of the
game bar winner barrel if I can't play
something I know it costs too much
elixir so that's good
that's crazy I love this amazing all
right very impressive holy hell oh yeah
calling me I really want this win that's
true I'm basically just cheating till I
get away maybe that idea gobbling giant
dart gob bandit rage lightning which
guards appease that states going in hot
I like it trust me
we're gonna do that maybe I should do
that well I've already sent the thing
but in the next one you should trademark
the very game yeah do you have different
uh nicknames for different kinds of Dex
that's like like to sweet baby
like the sweet baby deck you know like
I'm gonna hit with a sweet baby yeah
that's usually like you're winning there
yes it's nicknamed the winning game yeah
that's like the heavy necks like goal
giant he's like feet down pushes yeah
you can't stop it if you're like copying
elixir like towards really big push and
you can just get through crap so it's
interesting like so it sounds like so
much of this is a lot of it is really
feeling out the other player yeah yes
the first kind of seconds of the game
also kind of the first like matches it's
kind of like how are they playing what's
their strategy and then once you know
what they're using it's easier to like
know what you're playing against them is
so recognizing their deck early on is
important because then you know how your
deck is supposed to be used against
theirs right we're ready man all right
closing his eyes here we go oh man all
right you hear that you hear that that's
right
that's your death coming for you oh boy
oh my god no wait a second I'm going
remember training Blair training Sparky
in the corner spider don't tell me
you're doing okay here we go
oh this is oh yeah get him Sparky get
him I played Rascals into a Sparky oh
that's all right
oh wait I don't want to do that okay
here we go oh yeah get him get him
Sparky oh man oh this Sparky guy is
great all I need is like six Sparky's
basically even so far all right get the
skill ease out there skellies no that's
my ringtone
it was like I got a text message it's
just the same sound oh my god what are
those things okay
I didn't hear it though you it's a lot
of dude you look like Roman recruits
yeah we're all recruits reaching too low
I'm reaching too low put your art utq
barbarian
oh it's Apple I know he's right towers
well they got away from tower get the
Skelly's get the skellies that's all
right
you know what all right I stop I got a
shirtless dude running he's running real
hard okay here we go this is actually
I'm still losing but I feel like I'm
going to win I got a good I've got a
good I don't recommend this open
laughter happening in the back about my
performance all right recharge
okay here we get up you can boom stops
oh oh oh there we go there you go yes
yes all right get him you should be pro
player can't have got into your rage a
few longer I'm dressed for it man here
we go
all right the giant there seems to be
okay all right
hey fans Dave and Sparky here we go oh
wow owned right here my girl oh Jesus
God how do you guys keep up with this
all right no problem
oh wow big guy with a rash on his back
okay thank summer or something okay oh
my god so many dude oh my you just going
down no looking I'm not
[Laughter]
come on Skelly's oh Jesus God please
don't get out
hey guys how are you Boulton Mike and
Adrien hey guys how are you good you
guys are a complexity right yeah
complexity uh and so Colton the team
captain just beat me with his eyes
closed you're the team captain yeah well
how did you become the captain of
complexity I was the first one signed on
to the team okay right Elena helped
recruit the resident you recruited the
rest and where did you find them did you
just search in basements everywhere how
did you get these these these fast hands
in the game it was a you don't let him
touch you I'm sure he he's the recruiter
always so you guys are the best at this
game
right now how what did you have to give
up in your life to become number one at
clash Royale what are the things you've
given up
have you gone outdoors most last time
you went outside your coach now your
coach does he have you doing like
calisthenics eating right they do a lot
of dancing do you really did you juice
warm-ups what do you how do you warm up
before you play clash Royale listen to
music like dancing I'm just excited I'm
excited here and of course if you guys
are just joining us we got Conan O'Brien
here with complexity our Google Play
stream we're playing clash Royale today
clash Royale now guys I do how do you
like the game clash Royale alright
you've devoted your lives to it yes you
look at you you're paler than I am hi
I've never met someone pale put your
hair mouth look at that
dude you were built to play clash Royale
listen I like to tell you something I
know that complexity has devoted much of
their time to mastering the game clash
Royale I assure you that having never
played the game before I will now be
better than any of them now get me
started cold once you hook them up with
a cool deck and yeah it's good one of
you guys me up with a cool you have
different cards that you're gonna play
animus says animus prime says Conan is
completely lost here you are correct
animist prime you are correct in your
assessment that's right do you want to
say hi to YouTube Facebook and twitch I
refuse okay won't they ever said hi to
me well that's your last 45 minutes they
said hi everybody good to see you we got
YouTube YouTube Facebook we got twitch
we got Facebook in the house no one said
had said that in 20 years no one has
said in the house since you I mean
without irony since you didn't alive how
old do I'm 21
oh my god you were playing this game in
utero were you they were kinda way for
you to play this game Wow before you
were born
are you setting me up with a hot deck
he's gonna help you so Colton and I
versus these two guys I'm very good at
this game no I don't want to over use
your elite ability gotta save me I'm
touching him because he touches other
arouser what will be a good nickname for
Conan a clash Royale yeah eSports
circuit by storm and comes in and what
would it be good to get into the minds
of the Hidden Pony Minds he could be the
balcony
what's a Val coy
well Valkyrie is a girl and she has
right
then she's a warrior no I'll be that I
want to I want to be a girl with red
hair cuz that's what I was for most of
my childhood this is right there we go
she has an axe yeah
alright so Falco Conan Valcke boy
O'Brien you cut out spins as well so do
I let's do this let's go do this no
listen is it quote your real name Colton
Colton that's such a cool that's like
the name of a gunfighter in any other
era in human history you'd have been a
warrior a gunfighter I'm not saying this
is not good this is good but Colton is
such an amazing he what's your last name
whoa oh no he's coming to town who's
coming to town kolten Wong yeah that's I
would be terrified all right what do we
do I know you ready all right so let's
know how to play this game ablated let's
yeah start very slow you start slow all
right so this is a big tank and you got
him in the back and now you just wait no
I do anything you just ignore it because
this is how you can win I'm not doing
anything yeah so that's the goal there
moding at you they're yelling it so you
can yell at me all you want and I'm
yelling back don't win guys come on cry
yeah
I've got some nothing who doesn't get
through life without some dance yeah
that's a lesson for all of you young
people watching you've already done more
damage than blade didn't all hey not
wrong way yeah fact place not shouting
shouts constantly chosen I apologize my
insecurity he hasn't used his regular
speaking voice in ten years
okay well I'm so I'm just shouting Ren
I'm like a human emotion frowny mode I
mean he's trying hard to be a smile
emoji but it's just not in mm all right
this is poem listen I'm glad that you're
in shape because you have done nothing
this you have done next to nothing look
at him this guy is moving his hands
constantly and you are barely moving at
all look out chill Colton I know it's
just that whoa you know what we got a
killer deck you gotta have a killer
Debbie we're gonna play this game that's
what you know one thing I've always said
and I said this back in the 1970s way
clash Royale have Colton in a killer
deck I said that when Jimmy Carter was
president
look at that kids he was an actual
president just a one-term ribeaux
there's your girl there's my girl here
she goes yes
she's spinning the ball boy she died
that's terrible I'm sorry that she's
gone well didn't really know her that
well
who's winning so far cold not you you're
me what are you talking about you're the
one that's is doing everything how are
you why don't you do this all right I
can do it pressing things got it you got
it you got it you won did I just win yes
what is it
I won I took control did you notice that
whooping whoo Colton was like
and then I seized control from the
younger premillennial and made it happen
thank God guys what do you think huh
first time playing shirts hello you know
what yeah we the head would for you to
I'm not sure we're weapon I'm just about
to ask yeah I get one when you shout it
out as loud as you could they have one
for you too God what are you liking an
improv class once you want to say it
again - I'll set you up again
everyone's watching this live what do
you think we're gonna edit this they all
watched your blender line look at this
you guys actually have a shirt for me
and look at that it's got my name on it
now impart what was that noise that's
the sound an old mummy makes when you
suggest and a little bit of air from
3,000 years ago comes out ma'am now I'm
part of complexity this is great I think
we got time for only one more match so
let's get it let's get another greatest
time and I'm gonna go give me more
control this time yeah set me up with a
real plan more troll neck yeah so troll
deck for him do you guys ever bicker
after a match like if you let's say you
lost a match would you all bicker
amongst yourselves like you know colton
led us down the wrong do you guys fight
[Music]
you're a team every team
there's always infighting there's always
jealousy we try to avoid it yeah but you
know it's there you had problems last
year yes because when I dance with your
ass hurt them yeah before the matches
they dance together and he comes in he
sees them dancing Colton is very
controlling isn't yet alright so Wally
he's the one that has to set up the hot
deck there the other there are other two
players from their team are back over
here as well so you have the full team
wait why are they being punished back
there well they're not punished we don't
have room for this I'm sorry we don't
have room for them on the couch yeah
yeah that's the saddest thing I've heard
in a long time we didn't have a big
enough couch those are hard to come by
all right start the game and I'm just
gonna make it happen let's go this is
all me this one get me started here
started just get me started okay just
you know I know now you just play
whatever you want just play it behind it
okay so yeah he's just hitting he's just
hitting the thing yeah hitting the thing
he's not it's a good start so far god
what do you think of his technique cold
no let's just apple yeah just I mean
just Adrian's just like just thought he
hasn't done anything wrong right okay
right weight intensity yes I did be down
here mostly yeah that's fine yeah
typically you put on like your side yes
yeah when do I go to the card don't take
it yeah raspberries okay Lu houer
hmm that works yeah exactly that works
yeah here's what I do and I do this in
between you guys
do this and then do this with your hands
and it keeps the blood flowing in easy
way no card selected I'll give you a
card how's that that's our going own and
doesn't understand what he's doing he's
out of touch with the current generation
he shouldn't be in this room it's kind
of creepy but he's still here so so sad
Colton's freaked out guys not doing good
we're doing well we what
you guys no matter a command of English
than this guy why why is it looking down
now well you lost your tower
I lost my tower a long time ago I mean
it can if you think of it a certain way
but it really doesn't don't worry it's
all alive yeah what am i doing
yeah that works kind of course it works
you know what what
when Picasso is a paintbrush for the
first time it looks strange to people
what he was doing it was only later that
Picasso was hailed as oh no thanks good
yeah no but random will say you're
winning oh okay you wait what happened
victory who won did I win did you win no
why would you say I want if I didn't win
well it was it close at all was there
anything that I did accidentally like
let's say you let a dog loose a wild dog
in a chemistry class and he accidentally
bumps into a couple of beakers and for a
second it's like wait a minute I think
that dog accidentally did something
absolutely actually had a Sparky and the
princess killed the skeletons and then
killed the wizard and the witch that was
good yeah you ever listen to yourself
seriously if you walked into any
emergency room in this country and said
I had a Sparkie and a witch and then a
skeleton they would medicate you
immediately would call your parents and
shave your beard it's very unfortunate
just make sure you only talk this way
well you guys are playing the game yeah
we live together so it works of course
you live do that let me guess
and you have a bunk bed for three right
Bing Bing you have your own room yes you
all live together and what kind of
facility is this it's a it's a team
okay it's like a five bedroom house is
there any kind of parental supervision I
mean you're all very young we have a
manager who tell me more about this
manager you ever noticed that the
managers driving like the rest of you
were in an old cruddy van and the
manager has a Bugatti man and you're
like hey so about that we won that big
and he's like don't worry about that
I've got that handled
we travel in style I'm from Texas and I
brought my truck
Oh what kind of truck you have like you
can talk to me wait what when I say old
Chevy I don't say I have I once had a
1952 Ford f-150 that's an old truck and
I got rid of it because it had no brakes
and to stop it I had to roll it into a
tree but when you say I got a really old
car and I get excited and then you say
it's an OE Silverado
I'd blown away what do you drive um I
don't drive right now but back home I
have a CRV okay Honda do you ever forget
that you're driving a car and you start
pushing buttons and the next thing you
know you've hit 30 cars I can't say
that's ever happened but one day
remember well thank you everyone for
joining us we're out of time I'm sorry
to say we're gonna get a longer couch is
we wanted to have the rest the team but
our couch isn't long enough we're gonna
actually go to Ikea and get a couch
extension we will get a couch extension
for sure thank you to our exclusive
mobile gaming partners Google Play thank
you to supercell thank you to complexity
let's give it up for completely shirt is
OK with me
extreme cocoa guys good luck in your
match tonight yeah big match now
remember that's stay loose okay
don't yeah and don't get involved with
the ladies before the match you got to
stay clean and
laughter yeah of course clash Royale is
available on Google Play we will see you
guys next our Zealand